aux etats-unis les attentats suicide du
11 septembre sont dans tous les esprits
alors que l'on s'approche des
commémorations du cinquième anniversaire
le maire de new york a annoncé cette
semaine un vaste plan de financement
pour aider tous ceux qui sont intervenus
ce jour là et qui souffre encore dans
leur chair ces malades sont atteints de
troubles respiratoires des milliers de
secouristes bénévoles ou non qui ans qui
s'en suivit dans les hôpitaux aux
correspondances martine laroche-joubert
et parce qu'elle joue offrir leur voix
s'élèvent de plus en plus fort sur le
site de ground zero où les tours se sont
effondrées ya des sauveteurs des
ouvriers sur les lieux dès le 11
septembre 2001 aujourd'hui malade
parmi eux de nombreux immigrants sans
assurance maladie
c'est trop cher pour eux je demande de
l'aide depuis cinq ans pour ma santé
mais rien ne se passe quarante mille
personnes ont déblayé les décombres dans
des vapeurs toxiques sans être averti du
danger souvent sans masque ni gants et
ce pendant plusieurs semaines 70% à
chypre officiel souffre de graves
problèmes de santé et ne sont pas
correctement soigné votre nez à saigner
récemment ming a de la chance dans son
malheur il est suivi par les meilleurs
spécialistes policiers il a déblayé
pendant trois mois les ruines du world
trade center
je suis très limité dans mes mouvements
je me fatigue très vite j'ai du mal à
monter les escaliers je ne suis plus bon
à rien il n'y a aucun doute possible un
désastre de cette ampleur provoque
fatalement de très sérieux problèmes de
santé
à 43 ans épuisé ming a été mise à la
retraite
déprimé il retrouve un peu de paix dans
ce mémorial qui lui renvoie l'image d'un
héros bien sûr que je referais la même
chose il fallait aider tous ces gens ils
en avaient besoin
vito lui ne peut plus quitter sa maison
il se déplace en permanence avec un
appareil respiratoire qui lui procure de
l'oxygène le 11 septembre il travaillait
en face des tours et s'est proposé comme
volontaire j'ai pris le nuage de fumée
sur mon visage
toute cette poussière que j'imagine
plein de toxines et d'amiante s'est
passé directement dans ma gorge et j'ai
respiré tout ça c'était étouffant vito
est soutenu par son fils et son père
sont revenus ni assurance au ces
médicaments son appareillage lui sont
donnés par charité grâce à des bénévoles
mais les soins deviennent de plus en
plus lourd si je n'ai pas une greffe des
poumons je vais mourir pour cette
famille
il est déjà trop tard le père de ses
deux enfants policiers et meurent en
décembre 2004 après une longue agonie
il faut se souvenir de tous ces gens qui
sont morts le 11-septembre mais mon mari
lui aussi a souffert il ne pouvait plus
respirer
à la fin on l'avait affecté dans un
bureau j'étais très triste parce qu'il
aimait être dans la rue je ne sais pas
de plus en plus de malades gravement
atteints commence à sortir de l'oubli
le 11 septembre n'a pas fini de faire
des victimes